in Deutschland sind
261.000 Mietwagen unterwegs und die
bringen Millionen von Menschen von A
nach B für Urlauber Geschäftsreisen oder
wenn man seinen Crash beim ersten Date
beeindrucken will ich meine das ganze
ist super easy du bezahlst dafür holst
das Auto ab und fährst dreimal im Kreis
aber was passiert mit den Autos die du
in Köln abholst und beispielsweise nach
Berlin bringst irgendwie müssen die ja
zurückkommen ich habe herausgefunden
dass dafür Menschen beauftragt werden
und ziemlich viel Kohle bezahlt wird und
in diesem Video ihr habt es schon
vermutet machen wir genau das viel Spaß
mit Folge 3
[Musik]
nachdem wir im letzten Video eine Menge
Golfbälle verkauft haben ging es danach
super gut weiter 125 € konnten wir noch
mal extra verdienen die kommen also zu
unserem aktuellen Kontostand dazu es
gibt aber nicht nur positive Nachrichten
sehr geehrter Herr Henrichs wir bitten
Sie höflichst das Youtube-Video
bezüglich Golf Tauchen zu entfernen wir
werden den ganzen Tag mit Anrufen junger
Männer überhäuft die scheinbar wirklich
glauben dass man damit Geld verdienen
könnte kein Golfclub in Deutschland mit
dieser Aufgabe betrauen dafür gibt es
zertifizierte Profis bitte stoppen Sie
diesen Quatsch danke natürlich stoppen
wir den Quatsch nicht wir haben ja
gerade erst angefangen
im Prinzip habe ich eine Plattform
gefunden auf der diese
Überführungsfahrten angeboten wird ist
man also Sixt Enterprise Star car wer
auch immer und man muss eine Karre von A
nach B bringen dann stellt man eine
Anfrage in dieser App und Fahrer wie ich
können sich darauf bewerben und damit
Kohle verdienen hört sich cool an so
einfach wie genial aber wie viel Kohle
können wir damit wirklich verdienen
bevor man dann aber tatsächlich das
erste Mal hinterm Steuer sitzt muss
einiges passieren man muss den Account
erstellen und man muss alle nötigen
Informationen hinterlegen neben dem
Führerschein der bestätigt was man denn
so fahren darf auch ein polizeiliches
Führungszeugnis das leider 13 € kostet
als das alles erledigt war ging es
endlich an du bist zwei perfekte Fahrten
von Köln aus nach Mannheim oder nach
krämersheim in der Nähe von Mannheim
dann von krämersheim mit der Bahn nach
Mannheim fahren und den Mannheim ein
Auto abholen und das nach Duisburg
fahren was auch in der Nähe von Köln ist
was wenn ich heute noch an diesem Tag
hinbekommen würde ungefähr 250 € werden
dafür muss ich aber beide Aufträge
bekommen und wenn ich nur Auftrag
bekomme bin ich verpflichtet ihn
auszuführen und hängen dann irgendwo im
Süden von Deutschland fest aber wie
kommt man jetzt wirklich konkret an
einen Auftrag es gibt einen Auftraggeber
der ein Auto von A nach B bringen muss
der stellt die Fahrt online und diese
wird mit einem Listenpreis bepreist auf
diese Fahrt kann man sich jetzt bewerben
und ein eigenes Angebot machen steht
also eine Fahrt mit 130 € drin kann man
darauf Pokern die Fahrt mit einem
Angebot von 130 € auch zu bekommen gibt
es einen anderen Fahrrad der ein
günstigeres Angebot von 120 oder 110 €
macht ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ziemlich hoch dass er den Zuschlag
bekommt und das Auto für weniger als 130
€ von A nach B fahren darf
[Musik]
es ist also ein Bieterverfahren indem
man die Preise der anderen Mieter nicht
kennt und nicht sieht
aber sie können nicht sagen wie viel
runter
okay der perfekte Preis liegt also genau
in der Mitte zwischen attraktiv für den
Auftraggeber und lukrativ für uns und
das muss man irgendwie schätzen
in einer Minute
zwei Aufträge angenommen von Köln nach
Germersheim
Heilbronn nach Duisburg das bedeutet ich
muss irgendwie von Germersheim nach
Heilbronn kommen da können wir uns aber
später darum nein ich mache mich auf den
Weg nein ich habe ein Auto abzuholen für
onlogist
warum fährst du Autos ohne machst auf
YouTube rein genau dafür probier Kohle
zu vergehen und bei onlogist ja dafür
bezahlt ja genau ja
wie ist denn das mit den Autos muss ich
die tanken ich baller damit durch und
geht die Karre einfach wieder ab okay
geil C-Klasse
ganz entspannt 300 km darunter hacken
Service oder wann benutzt ihr unlogistik
die werden zurückverkauft damit Mercedes
die werden die gehen dann also
Jahreswagen an die Kunden raus okay
vielen dank schnell den Zustand des
Autos dokumentiert damit ist endlich
losgehen kann
ist komplett neu 19000 km gelaufen guckt
euch das an und dafür kriege ich über
100 € 300 Kilometer vielleicht die
Karriere jetzt Bildschirme ich mache mir
jetzt schön Mucke an Hängen mein Handy
ans laden muss selber nicht tanken die
Karre ist voll das ist der Luxus den ich
gebraucht habe nachdem ich das letzte
mal Geld im kalten Wasser mit dem
Golfbällen verdient habe jetzt einfach
mal ein bisschen entspannen paar Tage
mit den Autos rumfahren und das hier ist
ein sehr würdiger Einstieg in das ganze
Thema das dachte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt
noch ich bin in einer ausweglosen
Situation Müll wirklich Müll bezahlt
Digger so dann in der App hier einmal
als abgeholt markieren
jetzt wird das Tracking gestartet
und jetzt geht's ab
[Musik]
los geht's bevor ich aber jetzt gleich
mit diesem fremden Auto losfahren kann
muss ich vernünftig abgesichert sein wie
in fast allen meiner Videos die von
Spontanität und irgendwelchen verrückten
Ideen geprägt sind und da kommt klar der
Partner des heutigen Videos ins Spiel
Hitler hast du 360 Grad Kontrolle über
alle deine laufenden Verträge
unversicherung und in einer App dein
Ansprechpartner für Schadensfälle
Kündigung und Versicherungsvergleich mit
der App hast du 24/7 und on the go alle
deine aktuellen Versicherung immer zu
haben mit der Unterschrift bei der
Anmeldung wird klar zu deinem neuen
Versicherungsmakler über das Makler
Mandat vertritt klagt deine Interessen
gegenüber Versicherungsgesellschaften
und kann für Dich Verträge kündigen oder
abschließen das ganze aber natürlich nur
wenn du es möchtest Clark wird keine
Verträge hinter deinem Rücken
abschließen während du schläfst sondern
du behältst die volle Kontrolle ist
natürlich auch gesagt dass euch dieses
Makler Mandat nicht euer Leben lang
anklagt findet sondern ihr könnt es
kostenfrei wieder rufen es ist also der
perfekte Weg um Smart eure Versicherung
zu managen mit dem Code Dave oder über
diesen QR-Code erhaltet ihr bis zu 45 €
in Form eines best choice Gutscheins
zurück wenn Ihr drei bestehende
Versicherung hoch eingeladet und diesen
Gutschein könnt ihr bei hunderten vom
Partnern einlösen darunter dem App Store
about you und vielen weiteren Partnern
überzeugt euch aber am liebsten selbst
klickt auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung ladet euch die
clark-app runter fügt eure Versicherung
hinzu Vergleich diese und versichert
euch ab vielen Dank an klagt fürs
unterstützen dieses Videos und möglich
machen dieses Projektes und euch viel
Spaß weiter mit dem Video und genau
hiermit startet jetzt erste Fahrt von
Köln nach Germersheim 287 km 2 Stunden
und 56 Minuten
Ankunftszeit 16:52 Uhr also im
Zweifelsfall wirklich noch genug um die
zweite Karre zu holen und je länger ich
auf der Autobahn war je länger diese
Autofahrten desto klarer wurde mir aber
ein kleines das stimmt nicht ich habe
einen sehr großes Problem ich bin
pünktlich um 16:45 Uhr am ersten
abgabepunkt und muss bis 18 Uhr am 2
Abholung sein das bedeutet ich habe eine
Stunde 15 Zeit das Ding ist heute ist
der Tag an dem gestreikt es fährt keine
einzige Bahn wirklich keine Bahn also
ich kann das mit der Bahn auf keinen
Fall schaffen dann dachte ich okay kein
Problem ich fahre mit blablacar komme
aber wirklich auf dem letzten Mülldorf
raus von wo niemand Richtung Heilbronn
fährt wirklich niemand blablacar fällt
also auch raus und die letzte Option und
quasi das einzige was mir übrig bleibt
ist dieses Auto noch nicht abzugeben ich
darf das bis zum 29.03 behalten also
noch drei Tage behalte ist bis morgen
und schlafe heute Nacht ohne Kopfkissen
ohne Decke ohne alles in diesem Auto wo
die Karre eigentlich abgegeben werden
soll ab dadurch keine Kosten fürs Hotel
und ich darf in diesem Projekt ja meine
Reichweite nicht benutzen dürfte ich
meine Reichweite benutzen hätte ich
lieber insta Story gefragt ob sie eine
Möglichkeit gibt dass ich bei irgendwem
von Euch pennen darf das ist aber keine
Option also werde ich wenn jetzt nicht
gleich irgendein Wunder passiert die
Nacht in diesem Auto verbringen
bin da in der Stadt aus der ich nicht
mehr wegkomme Germersheim was geht ab
Digger das hier scheint mein Schlafplatz
zu sein Industriegebiet [__] me [__] me
[__] me double [__] Alter in meiner
absoluten Verzweiflung habe ich jede
Person angesprochen die ich gesehen habe
kennen Sie irgendeine Option ohne Auto
und ohne Zug nach Heilbronn zu kommen
noch fliegen ja wir haben 16:42 Uhr
spätestens um 17 Uhr müsste ich
losfahren damit das klappt und ich fahre
jetzt hier über den Parkplatz und Suche
nach Heilbronner Kennzeichen wenn ich
eins finde bleibe ich stehen und hoffe
dass jemand ganz kurzfristig nicht
einfach mitnimmt RP AAA
aus Heilbronn double double triple for
Triple [__] so und damit ist jetzt
ziemlich offiziell ich schaffe es nicht
mehr on time nach Heilbronn ich bin
offiziell in Germersheim gestrandet
glücklicherweise mit diesem Auto wo ich
jetzt heute Nacht drin nächtigen werde
ohne Decke ohne Kissen nächster Punkt es
ist 17 Uhr es ist nicht mal so dass ich
irgendwie von 23 Uhr bis 6 Uhr morgens
überbrücken müsste sondern
wir haben 17 Uhr
was soll ich Euch erzählen
genau so begann die wohl unangenehmste
und längste Nacht meines Lebens
meine Aussicht draußen ist mega kalt und
ich sitze und warte
[Musik]
wir haben zwei Uhr 24 das ist spooky es
ist zu hell es ist zu kalt ich habe
Rückenschmerzen ich kann nicht pennen
einfach der übelste Müll
es ist Zeit die Kamera abzugeben und ein
Formular später war es endlich geschafft
ich konnte den Auftrag abschließen war
endlich fertig Digger alle ohne
Kennzeichen nur Benz Mercedes Smart
Mercedes Smart Digger what the [__]
Maybach
ich habe gerade den übelsten Schock
bekommen und dachte irgendjemand hat mir
heute Nacht was an die Karre geschmiert
und ich habe es nicht mitbekommen oder
irgendwas kaputt gemacht einfach scheiße
die hier komplett über die Seite von der
Tür gegangen ist bei junge
das war's das erste Karre abgegeben ach
schon wieder kämen GT4 so nah und doch
so fern meinte der Schlüssel steckt
endlich ging es weiter von Germersheim
über Karlsruhe nach Heilbronn mit dem
Zug Ticket dass mich 14 € und 15 Cent
was nervig ist wo wir aber auf keinen
Fall drumherum gekommen werden
einzige was mich da noch aus dem Bruch
hätte rausholen können wäre ein Auto wie
auf der Hinfahrt gewesen aber auch da
wurde ich enttäuscht alles
unterschrieben alles bestens und damit
geht es jetzt 350 Kilometer mit dem
Renault Clio Richtung Duisburg nicht mal
nach Hause sondern nach Duisburg wenig
pS Leider Wagen halt Getriebe ich hoffe
dass das hier Bluetooth hat aber wir
wissen ja wofür wirst du ne nämlich fürs
eigene KFZ gerade übrigens äh zufällig
gelesen ich hätte gar nicht in dem Auto
pennen dürfen weil man darf das gar
nicht über Nacht behalten ja ja
bin scheinbar wirklich da es sieht
wieder industriell aus wie wird das Auto
abgegeben und damit sollte dann final
nach diesem absoluten hören Trip die
zweite Fahrt enden wenn die jetzt noch
die Karre annehmen ja schick mich wieder
nach Hause und ich schlafe wieder im
Auto wie zum Fick soll ich hier gleich
wieder wegkommen so auf ein letztes Mal
zumindest für heute
wunderbar geben wir die Karre mal ab
[Musik]
nach diesen absolut verrückten 24
Stunden mit allen Apps und Downs hatte
das Schicksal aber noch ein paar mit mir
und das ist ich schwöre das ist kein
Witz glücklicherweise wurde gleichzeitig
in Duisburg ein Auto von einem anderen
überführungsfahrer abgegeben mit dem ich
ins Gespräch gekommen bin und der mich
von dort direkt mit nach Köln nehmen
konnte und meld dich bei insta
vielleicht musst du legit Check geben
dass sie mich mitgenommen hat was könnt
ihr uns vielen Dank fürs Mitnehmen ciao
ciao das war wie kommt man nach zwei
kompletten abfucktagen komplett
kostenlos bis genau vor mein Haustür
natürlich nicht genau vor meiner Haustür
schön bescheuert euch jetzt zu sagen wo
ich wohne aber in die Nähe im Prinzip
lief alles wieder nach Plan also klar es
gab kleinere Schwierigkeiten ich musste
im Auto schlafen und so weiter aber der
Umsatz hat gepasst und alles war bestens
das ist zu Auto und Abholung 3k Auftrag
Nummer 3 und das ist unglaublich eine
fahr t innerhalb von Köln Hinfahrt und
Rückfahrt ich glaube ich muss Ihnen eine
Karre in einem Werkstatt bringen oder
irgendwie so 55 € minimaler Zeitaufwand
ich kann mit meinem eigenen Auto
hinfahren ich komme genau dort wieder an
wo ich das Auto angenommen habe kann
also mit meinem eigenen Auto wieder
zurückfahren und das ganze sollte mich
so ungefähr zwei Stunden Kosten dafür 55
€, das ist schon richtig gut dann fahren
sie ab und bringen sie dorthin los
ich habe ein Auto abzuholen von ATU
mit meinem Auto gehofft aber das war
schon heute Vormittag und ich habe sonst
keine weitere Infos die Dame am Abholort
wusste also nichts von dem Auto wirklich
gar nichts stellt euch mal vor das wäre
passiert meinem Auto dass ich 500 km
entfernt abholen will er ist völliger
Quatsch jetzt hoffe ich dass ich
irgendwie an die Kohle komme ich meine
ich hatte ja jetzt auch einen Aufwand
ich war on time da wir werden sehen was
daraus wird 55 € wären das im
Zweifelsfall die uns durch die Lappen
gehen was für uns überhaupt nicht
leisten können da gilt ist die Person
die dafür zuständig ist zur Rechenschaft
zu ziehen was soll ich machen
zurzeit sind alle Mitarbeiter
verlässt meinen Körper
hi David ich rufe an weil ich eigentlich
einen Auftrag hatte und niemand wusste
von dem Auto auch nicht von dem
Kennzeichen
heute morgen das war um kurz vor 9 Uhr
habe ich diesen Auftrag storniert und
auch eine Benachrichtigung rausgeschickt
okay weil das kam alles nicht an
trotzdem dahin gefahren
ist kein Problem sie werden dafür
bezahlt
ah gut ja vielen Dank dann werde ich das
wohl über den Rechtsweg bei unlogist
Regeln müssen ich schwöre es euch ich
werde alles dafür tun dass dieses Geld
bei mir ankommt kurz vor 9 Uhr wir haben
es gehört hat die den Auftrag storniert
11 Uhr um 11 Uhr sollte ich die Karre
abholen um 9 Uhr hat die den
[Musik]
wenn die war ja sehr nett aber bei Geld
hört die Freundschaft auf 55 € die mich
weiter davon trennen einen Porsche zu
haben die lasse ich mir nicht von so
einer scheiß ATU Filiale nehmen was soll
ich sagen 285 € Umsatz - all die tollen
Kosten die wir hatten ergibt diesen
Gewinn in dieser Folge los ein Auftrag
über 55 € über den über den Tisch
gezogen wurden wo ich natürlich versuche
anders Geld dran zu kommen dazu aber
mehr in den nächsten Folgen von gestern
nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren damit ihr
das nicht verpasst und diesem Video ein
Like da zu lassen wenn es euch gefallen
hat wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder
macht es gut ciao
[Musik]